-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Salma Hayek.
And you mentioned
this sort of long layoff
between this big action film
But you've got another one
coming up too.
This is a film that everybod
is very excited about.
It's Chloé Zhao, who is
obviously an incredible director
and she's doing "The Eternals.
It's a Marvel film.
And it must be so exciting
to get asked to do that.
-I was super excited,
especially because
I was already fond of Chloé.
Now she's one of the few
Oscar winner female directors.
But even then I was a superfan
and it was super exciting
also to do a Marvel film.
And the only weird thing i
that they don't let you
read the script.
-Yeah.
-You have to sign the contract
without reading the script
It was really strange.
I did it. I did it.
I was nervous.
But I trusted her.
And then there's another thing
You're like, "Yes, oh, my God,
I got a Marvel...!"
Like, what are the odds, right
at my age?
But you cannot tell anybody.
And I was one of the first ones.
You cannot tell your mother.
You cannot tell your father.
Because let me tell you,
they cannot hold a secret.
You cannot tell your kids.
It was torturous.
Finally we got to say it.
-And when you said
you didn't see the script,
so how much did Chloé tell you
about your character
that was enough informatio
for you to say yes?
-Not enough. No, she said,
"Your character,
she -- it's an Eternal.
Not she or he because
it's an Eternal.
And the Eternals
have a mission on Earth.
And out of the Eternals,
you're the only one
that talks to the Celestials
and so you're in charge."
And that's it.
Take it or leave it.
And it's -- still today
it's the only thing I'm allowe
to say to you about the movie.
The rest is still a secret
When you pay the ticket,
you will know what's the rest.
We signed a contract,
then they gave me the script
-I'm sure
it will be worth waiting.
Now, you are --
you have many animals,
but I think you're the first
person I've ever talked to
who has a pet owl.
And how did this come abou
because --
-Oh, Seth, did you have to sho
that specific picture?
-I mean,
did you have to take it?
[ Laughs ]
-I know, I know.
-Here's another one.
Here's another one.
You look very sporty here.
-And there are the dogs.
See, there is the dog also
-And there's the owl.
-I love my owl.
I didn't know much
about owls when I got --
one thing that really
impresses me is that
they don't drink any water
-Uh-huh.
-They just get all the water
from the rat that they eat
-Oh. [ Chuckles ]
I didn't know that either.
-Yes.
All the juices are soaked in
And that's all the liquids
that they need.
And however,
they don't eat other food.
They don't try to eat your food,
like my dogs.
-How often does an owl
need a rat to eat?
-Depending on the weather
and the weight
and the size of the rat,
but about twice a day.
-Oh, wow.
-About twice a day.
-So you got a lot of rats
around the house?
-No, order them.
You order them.
I don't know if I'm allowe
to say the name of the company
where you order everything else?
-Blue Apron?
Is it Blue Apron?
[ Laughter ]
-No, no.
-[ Laughs ]
So, you got an owl without
knowing much about the owl
and you just explained,
you said yes to "The Eternals"
with very little information
It seems like you're a perso
who jumps in with both feet.
-I'm an adventurer.
I'm an adventurer.
And you know what?
So is my owl.
-Yeah?
-Because --
She is very unusual --
she's female.
She does
a lot of strange things.
Even if I had known,
she still is very surprising
For example...
she likes wine.
Doesn't go for the food.
Doesn't go for the water.
She goes for the wine.
And you think, "Oh,
because it's red,
probably think it's blood.
Not that cheap wine.
If you have the cheap wine
she does not bother.
If you have a good red wine --
I have witnesses of this.
She goes -- I don't even kno
if she drinks it.
She just wants to put her head
inside or something.
You have to cover your glass
when you're in my house
at a party.
-I like the idea that if
someone comes to your hous
and brings a bottle of wine,
you pour it, and if the ow
doesn't eat it, you're offended.
-This is very good idea.
Before I drink it, I'm gonna see
if she goes for it,
because I'm too old
for a bad wine hangover.
-Yeah. That's a good call.
Hey, congratulations
on something else.
Before we go,
you're receiving a star
on the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Oh, yes.
-So well deserved.
Is that exciting?
-Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This is very exciting, yeah.
-How do you find out
something like that?
Who gives you the call?
-Oh, this time
they kind of surprised me.
I was on a call
with my publicist
and then people started
walking into the living room
and they were all talking.
I'm like, "Guys."
My husband is there,
my friend is there, you know
And all different nationalities,
everybody talking
in different languages.
And I'm like, "Shh! Guys."
And then -- and somebody comes
with a computer and puts it --
and all of a sudden
they turn on the TV
and there's a television show.
And I'm like, "Are you kidding
I'm trying to do business here."
And they --
they're like, "Look, look.
And I'm like, "What?"
And it's like a show,
and they start saying
all these names.
And I go, "What? What?"
And they said, "You got a star."
"What do you mean,
'You got a star'?"
"Yeah, the walk of Hollywood
star."
I said, "No, but there's
a lot of people.
I think I'm just nominated."
No, you got the star
with all the people.
I was so shocked.
-Well, incredibly well-deserved.
Overdue for my money.
And let me just say,
it is always
such a delight to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Same here.
Thank you so much.
Finally I made it to your show